welcome to the lecture on classifiers
so this is the point in the class
which we are going to change to our next
major topic so far we've talked about
in the main regression problems where
the target variable y
is a real number or a real vector
and now we want to switch to a different
problem
and this problem is called
classification
in classification the target value the
target variable
v is categorical it can only take
a finite number of possible values
and we will call that set script v
now these problems of classification
are treated in a very similar way
to regression in that we will
have a performance metric have a loss
function
have do empirical risk minimization
with regularizers but then there are
also
specific attributes of classification
problems which distinguish them
from regression problems
in particular we'll see that the type of
loss functions we use
is different that there is uh
that there are particular types of error
which can occur in a
classification problem that cannot occur
in a
regression problem and there are ways
of specifying the
nature of the predictor for
classification problems which
are different from how we would do those
in
regression we will also have a chance to
talk about
probabilistic regression
yeah in a later section of the class
now the set script v its elements
are denoted v one through v capital k
it's called the label set it's the set
of possible values of v
the vi are called the classes or the
labels or the categories
and when when k is two this is called
boolean
classification in which case we usually
think about
script b as being true or false or
positive or negative
it's called multi-class classification
when
capital k is greater than 2 when we have
more
than two classes
then our script v might be yes maybe no
it might be uh places
or countries it might be languages
it might be the set of english words in
some dictionary
it might be the set of possible
orderings
of m horses in a race so that's the
m factorial set of permutations of the
numbers one
through m
very often we just number our categories
and so instead of thinking them as v one
through v capital k
we think of them as just the numbers 1
through k
so when we're predicting a categorical
raw
output v given a raw input u
that's called classification
um we will talk about boolean
classification
or multi-class classification and the
predictor is a map
from script u the rsu is our set of
possible
independent variables to script v the
set of target variables
we'll denote that by a capital g
remember that
in the regression section we talked
about little g
as being the projector and was
parametrized by theta
but also remember that little g was the
map from
x to y where x was an embedding
of u and y was an embedding of v
and so here we've named the map from u
to v capital g
and so v hat is capital g of u is our
prediction
of v given u and then g is called a
classifier
and one way to think about the
classification is to think about
which values of u
give a result of g of u is equal to
one which values of u if a result of g
of u is equal to two and so on
and if you think about that then what
we've done is we've classified
the inputs u into
k different categories or k different
classes
and those classes are mutually exclusive
and collectively exhaustive
so here's an example here we have
our set
capital u as uh
so capital u will be uh
the square the set of
points uh u1
u2 where i think the absolute value
of the components in this example
is between four and four
and our set v
is equal to minus one
or one we have two categories one of
which is minus one and the other one
of which is one and in this plot
you can see all of our data points so
here there's no
uh split into training and test set
this is just the training set and there
are
i think 100 points here and so we've got
100 data points
and for each data point we have a record
consisting of a u
which will be a point in the square
and a v which will either be a minus one
or a one
and so we have
four i between one
and n where n is 100 ui
is in script u the square and little v i
is either minus 1 or 1.
and we've denoted the points here we've
shown them in the plot
where so that uh minus one here
there are points with uh of that of
points with for which vi is -1
are shown as red points and points for
which
vi equals 1 are shown as blue points
so these are our 100 data points
now what a classifier has to do is a
classifier has to
map every point in
script u to
the minus 101 so that if somebody comes
along
later and says here is a new point
in u tell me what value for v
you predict for it give me v hat well
that's what the classifier does
and we denoted that in this picture by
shading
the square some of it is shaded
pink those points are points for which
we predict
an outcome which is -1
and some points are shaded blue where we
predict an outcome of 1.
and so if somebody comes along with some
new point let's make it some new point
right here then our prediction for that
point
would be that v hat is
minus one if it's here our prediction
is that v hat is one
and we're trying to learn the predictor
capital g we're trying to construct it
we're going to learn it from this data
set
and this particular predictor we haven't
talked about how to construct it yet
but this predict particular predictor
was learned from this particular data
set
and you can see it does okay
in particular if we look at how well is
it doing
on the training set well there are
points such as hit these points
where the true value
of v i is one and the prediction
so the true value of v i is minus one
and the prediction is also minus one
and there are points like these ones
where the true value is one and the
prediction
is also one but then there are
other points like this red point right
there
for that red point the true value
is minus one because it's a red point
but the predicted value is one because
it's in the blue region
and so these are points
for which our predictor is giving the
wrong answer
on the training data and there are some
points in the other with with
which make a different type of error
there are blue points for which we
predict
the outcome should be red and there are
red points for which the
we predict the outcome should be blue
one way to think about this is it's a
kind of
regression it's a kind of function
fitting
instead of our function assigning
a real number to every point
every possible value of u a function
is assigning a category to every
possible value of you
the category either being minus one or
one
the category being red or blue
this is a good picture to have in your
mind when you're thinking about what is
a classification problem
you've got a bunch of data points they
have colors associated with them
and you want to shade in the plane so
that
the predictions corresponding to your
shaded color
match up with the true colors of the
data points
and of course it's convenient to think
like that and in two dimensions of
course the problem is kind of easy
we can simply shade in the plane to
correspond to the colors of the points
that we see and there's no need for us
to
ever get it wrong but if i'm working in
d dimensions and d is large well then i
can't
hope to do this by hand and
i have to
come up with an algorithm that's going
to do this for me
let's talk about some applications of
classification
um here's an example medical diagnosis
view
is a bunch of patient attributes so the
fields
in patient record are test results
and age gender
height body mass a whole bunch of other
attributes for the person
and then the boolean v the target
variable
encodes some disease status has a
disease or not
or maybe it's multi-class
does the person have copied 19 flu
or just a cold
um if we're doing
advertising then you contains the
attributes
of a person the demographic data about
an individual
and it also contains information about
an ad
that's being shown to them and then v
encodes whether they will buy the item
whether they're going to click on the ad
etc
uh for detection so here you might
contain the attributes of a transaction
was it
in person was it over the phone was it
online
what kind of credit card it was was it
international
and then v is an attempt to
um it be the categories that b can be
either that it's a fraudulent
transaction or that it's a valid
transaction
and so one might have a whole bunch of
data
um where historic where we have
historical
data of transactions and they're labeled
instead either being fortunate
transactions or valid transactions
and we would learn from that data a
predictor
that when somebody makes a new
transaction
can be the attributes of that
transaction can be fed into the
predictor
and then the predictor would predict
whether or not that transaction
is fraudulent or valid
image classification here u is an image
that would be an array of pixels
and v would be uh
categories of possible objects within
the image
so we might be looking to categorize
natural objects lions and tigers and
bears
vegetation trees vehicles buses
and we might build a classifier
that you give it an image and it tells
you what's in the image
and one can do
simple things where one has an image
which we know
contains just one object
and the classifier has to return simply
which
object it is in which case script v is
just a list of possible objects
or we might do more complicated things
where the classifier has to return a
list
of all objects in the image
and that would be and then in that case
the
script v would have to contain not just
individual objects
but pairs of objects or lists of
possible objects
here's another one spam filtering this
was one of the very first
successes of the classification
methodologies which we're discussing in
this class
where you contains the attributes of a
mail message
the from address the to address
and also a description of the text
in the email message so which
words are in the text in particular and
then v
the target variables would uh
the categories would be either spam or
ham and of course meaning that it's
a good email message
and back in the uh
mid 1990s when email was becoming
very popular the
technique called bayesian classification
that we
may see later in this class we also only
see related techniques
which is one of the first successful
methods of
distinguishing spam from ham
another example application of
classification is sports forecasting
here u contains the attributes of a game
or a match
and team a versus team b so which teams
are playing attributes of the teams
themselves
and v encodes which game which
which of the uh team wins the game
or possibly a tie
uh topic detection so
u is an article or a news item and v
encodes the topic so politics sports or
business and so on
another example is sentence parsing so u
is a sentence
and v encodes the grammatical parsing of
the sentence
so that is a tree structure that encodes
the relationships between
the nouns the verbs the odd the
adjectives the adverbs and all the other
possible parts of speech
so when we're measuring the performance
of a classifier
there's a very natural performance
metric that
we have that is probably the most
commonly used
and that is the idea of the error rate
so uh if we have
uh a data set with u1 through un
and v1 through vn so we have n records
for each one we have a ui and a vi pair
where ui lies in script u and vi
is the target variable tells us which
class
ui belongs to
and then the predictions are given by v
hat i
which is g of u i
and uh a prediction is correct
if v hat is v when it's wrong or it's an
error if v has not v
the error rate e is the fraction of data
points
on which the predictor gave an incorrect
prediction
so in other words we look at all i from
1 up to n
we compare v i with v hat i and
if they're not the same well that's an
error and we count the number of errors
and divide by n and this is the simplest
possible
performance metric for a classifier and
once we've computed it
we can come uh use it to compare
different classifiers
and in particular we would do this not
only on the training set but on the
test set
now when we're working on with a
boolean classification where the set of
target variables
it has only two elements we'll call them
minus one on one
then we refer to the
class v is minus one as the negative
class
and the class v is one as the positive
and that allows us to use this very nice
terminology
about the possible outcomes
so we're going to be choosing v-hat
that's what our predictor does for us
and we've got a true v which is part of
the training
set and the v-hat
is one and b is one well then that's a
correct prediction
and we would call that kind of
prediction as true positive
if v hat is minus one and v is minus one
well that's also a correct correct
prediction and we'd call that a true
negative
and then there are two different types
of errors we can make
it could be that v is one but we predict
that v hat is minus one
and that's called a false negative or a
type 2 error
or it could be that v is -1 and v-hat
is 1 and that's called a false positive
or type 1 error
now once we've constructed a predictor
we can
construct a
statistic which describes the
performance
of the predictor and that's this thing
called a confusion matrix c it's a two
by two matrix
and uh its entries are
the number of true negatives the number
of false negatives
number of false positives and the number
of true positives
and when we look at this we should
realize that the first
column here corresponds to
v equals minus one the second one
corresponds to v
is equal to one and the first row
hat is minus one and the second row
corresponds to v
hat is one so in the first row we pick
v hat is minus one if we're in the first
column also then we've got a true
negative
if we're in the second column then we've
got a false negative
we also refer to these entries
individually as the number of true
negatives number of false positives
the number of false negatives and number
of true
positives c t n c f n c f p and c
t p and these are numbers
not rates so if we add up those four
numbers
they uh add up to n
which is the total number of data points
we have the total number of examples
uh we also have the number of negative
examples which we'll denote by
n with a little n as a subscript
uh it's the number of true negatives
plus the number of false positives
and the number of positive examples
which is the number of false negatives
plus the number of true
positives and these are sums
over uh the columns so this this
sum right here ctn plus cfp
that's equal to n in the number of
negative examples
and this sum right here is equal to n
p the number of positive examples
when we look at this matrix of course
what do we how do we get this matrix
well we have a predictor g
and we can evaluate it on the training
set
and that will give us a matrix c and we
can evaluate it on the test set and that
will give us another matrix c
and these two matrices these two
confusion matrices
are measurements of performance
now and when we look at them well what
we'd like to see
is large numbers on the diagonal because
the diagonals
are measurements of the number of times
in which we've made correct predictions
and small numbers in the off diagonal
because of the off diagonal entries are
incorrect predictions and that's what
they're counting and they're counting
separately the two different types
of incorrect predictions and the
diagonals are counting separately the
two different types of correct
predictions
now the uh
there are some very uh standard
terminology that surrounds the confusion
matrix that's worth going over
in particular the false positive rate is
simply
cfp divided by n and the false negative
rate is c
f n divided by n and the error rate is
the sum of those two
cfp plus cfn divided by n
uh there are also uh there's also a
whole bunch of other terminology that
people like to use
often in very specific fields so people
talk about the true
positive rate or the sensitivity or the
recall
that's ctp over np it's the fraction of
true positives which we
guess correctly uh the false alarm rate
is cfp on nn the fraction of true
negatives we incorrectly
guess as positive there's the
specificity
or the true negative rate which is ctn
on nn
the fraction of true negatives that we
correctly guess
and there's the precision which is ctp
on ctp plus cfp
which is the fraction of our positive
guesses that really are positive
and these are well they're used in
different fields quite a lot of them are
used in medicine
some of them are used in specific
branches of statistics
um we will i think never use
things like sensitivity or specificity
in this class um in machine learning
almost always people just look at the
confusion matrix
and the counts um which are
readily interpretable and readily
converted to one of these other measures
if you're
working in that appropriate field
now one of the things about looking at
the confusion matrix is that it
highlights for us that we have really
two
metrics for a boolean classifier
we'd like to keep both the false
positive rates more
and the false negative rates more and
the sum of those two numbers
is the error rate
and keeping the error rate small is fine
but sometimes it's not what you want out
of a classifier
so for example if you have
a manufacturing line you have a camera
that's looking at the objects that are
coming off the magic manufacturing line
and is trying to determine whether or
not
they are correctly manufactured or
incorrectly manufactured
if you've got very few errors in your
manufacturing process
then a huge percentage of
those manufactured objects will actually
be correctly manufactured and only a
very very small percentage will be
incorrectly manufactured
classification is often difficult for
such manufacturing problems
and very often the
predictor that minimizes the error rate
is simply to predict that all
of the objects coming off your
production line are actually correctly
manufactured
um however that's that's completely
useless of course because it's giving
you no information
what you're much more interested in in
such a situation
is to be able to detect those
bad objects
those incorrectly produced objects and
so one would have a classifier there
that is willing to incorrectly classify
a few good objects as bad
as long as it caught most of the bad
objects
and so there one is quite happy to
accept
a few false positives positive here
corresponding to bad objects
in exchange for a very small number of
false negatives
for where the false negatives there
would be incorrectly assuming that a bad
object is good
this is a very common situation that the
thing you're trying to detect
is where and so
choosing a classifier that minimizes the
error
gives us an uninformative classifier and
it's much better
to try to choose a classifier that
focuses
on either false positives or false
negatives
now we still need to be able to compare
classifiers
and it's very often convenient to have a
single metric
a number and the way we do that is we
combine them
with a weight so and that that's called
the name and pearson
metric enp it's
kappa times the false negative
rate plus the false positive
rate and so here kappa is some positive
number
and it sets how much we care about false
negatives compared to false positives
so cap is very large then our name and
pearson metric
is affected very much by false negatives
and not so much by false positives if
kappa is very small
then our name and pearson metric is
large when we've got a large number of
false positives
and not so much when we've got a large
number of false negatives
and kappa is one well then the name and
person metric is just the sum of the
false negative rate and the false
positive rate which is the error rate
let's look at this more conveniently
as a trade-off
graph if you pick any
classifier you designed it using
whatever your favorite
method of designing classifiers is and
we haven't told you how to do that yet
and then you say well okay i've got this
i've got a classifier and i can compute
its false negative and false positive
rate on on the test set
and that those are going to give me two
numbers
and i can plot those two numbers
on this plot right here so on the
horizontal axis here
i've got the the false negative rate and
the vertical axis
i've got the false positive rate
and so you give me any classifier i have
some particular point
there's one there's one
here's another and
so different classifiers correspond to
different points on this
uh on this plot
now one thing that's worth observing on
this plot is that there are some
classifiers
that you would just never use and one
is g3 and the reason you would use never
you would never use g3
is that if you compare it with g2
well g2 does better in terms of the
false
positive rate and the false negative
rate
and so g2
wins on both counts and if you're
interested even if you're more and
concerned about one of those measures
than the other one
you'd still use g2 over g3
if on the other hand we compare with
g1 well
if i compare g1 with g3
well g1 does better in the false
negative rate
but worse in the false positive rate
and so i might well use g3 instead of
g1 but if i've got g2
i would use g2 over g3
now if i compare g1 and g2 well that's
not so easy
because g1 has a smaller false negative
rate
but a larger false positive rate than g2
and those two classifiers are
incomparable
choosing between them is up to you
the designer of the system you may be
more interested in keeping the false
negative rate small if you're more
interested in keeping the false negative
negative rate small
then you should choose g1 if you're more
interested in keeping the false positive
rates more
then you should choose g2
if you have g2 available then you should
never choose
g3
so when you look at a classifier
on this plot the important classifiers
are one where are those for which there
is nothing
better in both false positive and false
negative so if i look at a particular
classifier
and say let's look at g2
and then if i draw here the region of
the plane
consisting of values
for the false positive and the false
negative rate which are
better than those achieved by g2 if
there's no classifier in that region
then it's a good classifier conversely
if i look at g3
and i look at the region consisting of
better performance well there are
classifiers
in that region so g3 is a bad classifier
now the good classifiers have a name
they're called
pareto optimal they're good because no
other classifier is better
in both false positive and false
negative rates
the set of all of these pareto optimal
classifiers so the pareto optimal
classifiers are these red points
so the set of all pareto optimal points
is called the operating characteristic
or the
rock rock stands for receiver operating
characteristic
this is a term that goes back to the
design of
radar systems in world war ii and almost
nobody calls it the
receiver operating characteristic
anymore almost always it's just referred
to as the rock
and so what we commonly do is we develop
many different classifiers
and we plot them on this plot we rule
out the ones
which are bad which are not burrito
and then out of the ones that are
burrito we get to make our choice
now when we've got the neyman pearson
measure that's kappa times the false
negative rate
plus the false positive rate well
what that's doing is it's measuring
performance in a particular
direction in this plane and so
when i think about this i'll call
uh i've got the false negative rate and
the false positive rate
and i can if i've got a particular kappa
i can draw a vector
there's a vector and that vector
is in the direction
kappa 1
and so i can think about my false
my name and pearson metric has kappa
1 transpose
c f n on n c
f p on n
now because we're using the vector kappa
multiplied by the vector
of coordinates in this plane what that
measures
is it measures the distance from the
origin
in the direction kappa 1.
and so if we look at the set of all
points
which are for which kappa 1
transpose multiplied by the coordinates
of that point is equal
to say 1
that would be
a line here
and then if we look at the set of all
points for which that linear combination
kappa 1 transpose multiplied by the
coordinates is equal to 2
it would be a different line and so on
and so by minimizing
kappa times the false negative rate
plus the false positive rate we are
trying to pick the point
that is on
the line of these lines which is closest
to the origin in this particular case
the point is g2
for this particular value of kappa shown
here
and these lines have a slope of minus k
minus kappa and so by
varying kappa between zero
and infinity we we have slopes when
kappa
is zero we have uh
uh
a vector pointing in this direction and
when kappa is very large
we have a vector pointing in this
direction
so we can pick kappa um
according to our preference if we make
kappa
very large then we're going to try
and minimize we're going to try we're
going to have a slope
lines that look like this and we're
going to try
we're going to be concerned about
performance
where the best thing
one can do in order to
make the performance measure small
is to choose a predictor
that has a low false negative rate
if instead we
use a kappa which is very small well
then kappa
1 looks
a vector like this and we're going to
have
corresponding
lines in this direction and the best
thing we can do to make that
performance metric small is to pick a
predictor for which the false positive
rate
is small
here's an example um here we have
the same data set that we showed before
we have blue points and red points
the red points are -1 and the blue
points
have target variable 1.
we can see there are some false
negatives
the false negatives are blue points for
which the classifier would predict
red so
whereas a false negative
there's one false negative right in
there
underneath there there was a blue dot
which i will now
make visible there it is
so this blue dot there is
in the red region it's in the region
which i'll classify will predict red
that's a false negative and then there
are many false
i positives all of these red dots
are points which we would predict
predict as blue we'd give a positive
prediction but it's a false positive
if you count the number of red dots the
false in the blue region
that for classifier number one that
turns out to be sixteen
and we've already seen that there's uh
one
blue dot in the red region and so
this here is our false negative
this here is our 16 false positives
this is our these are correct
predictions
of minus one so these are red dots in
the red region and there are 24 such red
dots
and these are blue dots in the blue
region
and there are 59 such blue dots
now if we on this particular test
on this particular example there are 100
points
and so the
false negative rate is
0.01 and the false positive rate is 0.16
and we can plot those false negative
rate is 0.01
false positive rate is 0.16 well
there's 0.01 there's 0.16
that's predictor 1 right there
we can look at predictor 2. this is a
different predictor you can see it's got
different regions
and this predictor is
uh encompassed more so when you look at
these this set of data set
this data points you can see that it's
largely
uh
let me erase that
it largely consists of
blue points going across the middle here
and red points going this way
and so our predictor here is focused
on getting the blue points
covered by blue region and
unfortunately it's going to have some
red points covered as well and that's
why
it's got a large number of
false positives because the
uh the red points have been classified
as blue
here we've said well we don't want that
anymore we won't like to
balance the um
the red and blue errors and so we've
got a predictor that is classifying more
of the red points
is actually red more of the region in
which the red points are
is has a corresponding prediction
of red as a result we can
look here and we can see well now there
are eight
false negatives
there's one um
but there's only eight false positives
here's one
and that gives us a corresponding false
positive and false negative rates of
0.08
which is right there
here's a plot number three is a
classifier at the other extreme
here we've tried to focus on getting the
rid
points correct and in exchange
we're getting some of the blue points
wrong what does that mean in terms of
false positives and false negatives
it means that we've got very few false
positives
and a large number of false negatives
our false positives are red points
that are classified as blue
and there are two of them here is one of
them
um and we've got a large number of blue
points that are classified as red
there's one of them our
resulting counts uh
there are 23 false negatives
and two false positives and that gives
us
this classifier right there
so there are three classifiers um
and which one you pick out of those
three
that's up to you there is no
way of choosing between these three
classifiers
number two beats number three
in false negative rate but does worse in
false positive rate
number one beats number two in the same
way
um and uh
neither one of them we would say neither
one of them dominates
the other and so
this is a design question it depends on
the particular
problem that you're looking at whether
you're interested
in a classifier that has smallest
overall error rate let's look at what
the
overall error rates are so this one has
an error rate
of 17. this one has an error rate
of 16 and this one has an error rate
of 25 and those are error counts error
rates are 0.17
0.16 and 0.25
so the one with the smallest error rate
is number two
the one with the smallest number of
false negatives
is number one and the number one with
the smallest number of false positives
is number three
now when you look at multi-class
classification
well there are no longer just four
possible
values for v hat and v there are
k squared possible values because there
are k
classes v1 to v capital k
and uh and each of v
hat and v can be in
any one of those classes so k squared
possible
outcome pairs
when we say v hat is v i and v is v j it
means
the true value is v j and we're
predicting v i
so the only ones that are correct are
when v i is v
j and it's incorrect when v i is not v j
in other words
if v hat is v that's correct and if v
hat is
not v that's incorrect so there are
k different ways in which we can make
the same make a correct prediction
if we predict v1 and the truth is v1
that's correct if we predict v2 and the
truth is v2 that's also correct
um but there's also a bunch of different
errors
if we predict v1 but the truth is v2
well then that's an error but there's a
different error
where the truth is v2 and we predicted
v3
so there are k times k minus 1 types of
errors one for each
possible pair where i is not equal to j
so we have a k by k confusion matrix
and the ijth entry of the mate confusion
matrix c
is the number of data records
where we guessed we predicted v
hat was v i but actually the true v was
v
j um you should be aware that sometimes
uh people transpose this so they swap i
and j and
of course that's just a convention
of course the entries in c add up to n
the number of data points the column
sums give the number of records
in each class
c i i is the number of times we
predicted v
i correctly if i is not j
then c i j is the number of times we
mistook
v j for v i
now these quantities c i j where i is
not equal to j if we normalize them by
the number of records n
that's called the error rate for those
particular pair
of classes e i j
is the number is the fraction of the
data points on which
we mistake v j for v
i and the overall error rate
is the sum of all the different error
rates
so here's an example here we've shown
data points which have target value one
is red
two is green and three is blue and we've
got a classifier
that classifies points in the plane
as either red green or blue
and you can see that it's doing okay uh
the green region mostly contains green
points
the blue region mostly contains blue
points in the red region mostly contains
red points
there are a few cases where we have
green points but they would be predicted
as red
here's one two three
four five so
those are green points that we would
predict as red
and there's a blue point that we would
predict as red as well that's this one
right here
and so there's one of that type of error
as well
what other types of error are there
there's a red point
that we are predicting is green
there that's this error
and there's a green point that we're
predicting is blue
that's this point right there and that's
this error
all the other points are correctly
classified we've got 39
reds that we're classifying as red 34
greens that we're classifying as green
and 17 blues that we're classifying as
blue
now to take the error rates well there
are 100 points so i simply take all the
non-diagonal
or the off-diagonal entries of the
confusion matrix
divide them by 100 and that gives me
the error rate matrix there and if i sum
up all of these different errors
i'll find there's a 10 error rate
now just as
[Music]
in the boolean case when we want to
pick a classifier it's very often
convenient to have one number
that measures that is our performance
metric
and the way we would do that is we would
use a weighted sum
of the different types of errors now you
could attach a weight
to all of the different categories of
errors so in our
three class example there are six
possible types of errors and so you
could have six
different kappa values and use those six
different kappa values
to weight the different errors
and that would be a perfectly fine
performance measure in fact we don't do
that
what instead we tend to do is we tend
to use a kappa value
which is only defined per
column per true class
and so we'll have one weight which is
associated
with these two errors one weight
associated with these two errors
and one weight associated with those
two errors in the last column
and so associated with each column
there's the error
rate which is we're denoting my e sub j
it's the number of times we mistook vj
for some other class
and we could divide by n and get the
error rate as well as the error count
and then we take a weighted sum of these
three error rates and that's the name
and
pearson error
so kappa j is then how much we care
about mistaking vj for something else
and if kappa j is one for all of the
different eyes
then the name and pearson era is the
error rate we're just summing up all the
different errors
so to summarize in this section we've
talked about
how you measure performance of
classifiers
both for boolean classifiers and for
multi-class
classifiers we haven't yet talked about
how you find classifiers
and that's coming in the next section
you